something called the Dunning Krueger
effect the more you learn in a specific
skill the more you realize you don't
know and so if right now you're young
and you think you know a lot I want to
tell you it's a psychological fallacy
like you actually know nothing like you
think you know it which is why it's a
fallacy and the reason that some people
are older have to stain for people who
are younger is because of this
psychological effect people who are
older who have had more experience
realize they know less and then see
somebody who's younger thinks they know
more and they realize the discrepancy
and how ignorant it is and you just look
stupid